[Musik]
24 Februar alles angefangen hat habe ich
gedacht ja das war überfällig aber
besser später als nie
als Wladimir Putin im Februar 2022 seine
Panzer in Richtung Kiew schickt schaut
die Welt mit Entsetzen zu
Millionen Russen aber unterstützen den
Überfall auf das Nachbarland
[Musik]
getan hat war notwendig weil die
Bedrohungen durch das Regime in Kiew für
unseren Staat nicht mehr zu ertragen
[Musik]
ich konnte nicht schweigen und deshalb
schrieb ich kein Krieg Russen gegen den
Krieg
eine gespaltene Gesellschaft
es gibt keine unabhängigen Standpunkte
es gibt nur die Propaganda der einen
Seite oder die der anderen Seite oder
einer dritten oder vierten Seite
warum sind fast 60% der Russen für den
Krieg trotz hoher Verluste und senkender
Truppen rein
sie plünderten alles was sie in die
Finger bekam Schmuck Edelsteine Autos
und was sie nicht stehlen konnten
zerstörten sie
[Musik]
Russland auf dem Weg in einer ungewisse
Zukunft
nach Putin könnte leider ein anderer
Putin kommen ein anderer verrückter ein
anderer Mensch der mit dem Säbel rasselt
und der Welt mit einem Atomschlag droht
[Musik]
in Putins Russland ist es ein Verbrechen
gegen den Krieg zu protestieren jede
Kritik kann Gefängnis bedeuten
es war mir völlig egal was mit mir
persönlich passiert
denn die russische Armee war dabei die
Ukraine zu zerstören überall gab es Blut
und Tod überall gab es leid Daniel
die Journalistin Marina auf seine Kova
steht vor Gericht weil sie den Krieg
kritisiert hat
die Folgen für Sie und Ihre Kinder sind
nicht absehbar ihr drohen zehn Jahre
Haft
[Musik]
Millionen Russinnen und Russen jubeln
Putins Agitatoren zu die für den Krieg
werben sie sind Sprachrohre des Regimes
nutzen ihre Popularität für eine
pro-kriegsbotschaft füllen Stadien und
laufen live auf Kanal 1 dem Haussender
des Krems
wir sind das russische Volk wir lieben
unser Land wir sind für eine Welt ohne
Nazis wir sind für unsere Armee für
unseren Präsidenten für unser Vaterland
für den Sieg wir werden fliegen
[Applaus]
Ivan von der Kopf ist putinfan und ein
sogenannter z-poet seine Videos auf
Youtube werden hunderttausendfach
geklickt auf telegram ist der Star
[Musik]
er ist Prophetin pro Krieg und hast den
Westen
[Musik]
wurden immer populärer sie sagten wie
gut es sei in Europa zu leben und das
ist in Russland so schlecht ist das hat
mich aufgeregt weil sie dreist gelogen
haben
[Musik]
Mann
warum haben Sie das Recht zu lügen und
ich nicht das Recht die Wahrheit und
meine Meinung zu sein
der politische Westen ist voll von
Wundern fast jeder landesführer ist ein
bunter Diktator da sitzt der schöne in
Kanada der Curry Diktator in der Downing
Street der lustige Glatzkopf in Berlin
und der Fette schweinediktator mit
seinem Gesicht den Kokain
wirklich wütend macht in die Lage in der
Ukraine
im Grunde genommen hat der Westen
angeführt von den USA die Ukraine
besetzt sie haben eine
Marionettenregierung installiert
[Musik]
nicht alle Russen denken so wie Ivan
ich will dass sie das Gesetz befolgen
Menschenrechtsanwältin Anastasia
budakova ist seit 2011 politisch aktiv
als Putins Regime die Freiheitsrechte
einschränkt will sie das nicht hinnehmen
um die russische Zivilgesellschaft wurde
langsam eine Mauer errichtet ein
unsichtbarer eiserner Vorhang aber da
ist dem landwirtschaftlich recht gut
ging haben die Menschen das nicht
bemerkt hinzu kam die tägliche
Propaganda es hieß politische Teilhabe
sei nicht notwendig
mir wurde klar dass es kriminell ist
sich nicht politisch zu beteiligen denn
im Prinzip hängt von uns allen ab was in
unserem Land geschieht
trotz mutiger Menschen wie Anastasia
werden die bürgerlichen Freiheiten in
Russland immer weiter ausgehöhlt
[Musik]
ich würde sagen dass die
Zivilgesellschaft völlig am Boden lag
als Russland in der Ukraine
einmarschierte Aktivisten die in
Russland geblieben sind sind jetzt
politische Gefangene Organisationen die
versucht haben weiter zu arbeiten und
das Recht zu schützen wurden verboten
Anastasia arbeitete als Anwältin für
Verfolgte Oppositionelle
ich wollte so lange wie möglich in
Russland bleiben um mich für die
Menschenrechte einzusetzen
aber als ich vor der Wahl stand ins
Gefängnis zu gehen oder Russland zu
verlassen habe ich mich entschieden
auszureisen in Freiheit bin ich von
größerem Nutzen
Anastasia flieht und liebt jetzt den
tiefes Georgien
so wahnsinnig ist und jetzt führt er
einen Krieg in unserem Namen seine Armee
Menschen durch Propaganda zumbifiziert
zerstören ukrainische Städte
Anastasia gründet das arc-project sie
hilft Flüchtlingen aus Russland
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
es gibt auch psychologische Hilfe für
Menschen aus Russland die gegen den
Krieg sind sich deshalb schuldig fühlen
Sie wissen oft nicht was sie tun sollen
um damit fertig zu werden
[Musik]
und natürlich ist auch gute
Unterbringung eine echte Hilfe
passiert das wirklich jetzt
2022/2023 zu meinen Lebzeiten und sind
meine Mitbürger wirklich die Täter
Menschen mit denen ich in den
Kindergarten in die Schule gegangen bin
[Musik]
für Russinnen wie Anastasia ein Albtraum
in ihrer Heimat wird nur noch Putin
Sicht auf den Krieg toleriert
[Musik]
der Blogger Iwan contakov sagt seine
Überzeugung sei so wie bei vielen durch
die bittere Erfahrung nach dem
Zusammenbruch der Sowjetunion in den
90er Jahren geprägt worden an
Gorbatschows Perestroika gibt es für ihn
nichts schön zu reden
[Musik]
seine Reformen waren ein Fehlschlag und
es war von Anfang an nicht klar was er
eigentlich wollte das Volk mochte und
mag ihn nicht die Menschen sehen in ihm
einen Verräter
für Ivan ist der Werbespot einer
us-pizza-kette beispielhaft für
Gorbatschows Anbiederung an den Westen
[Musik]
im Fernsehen wurde uns von der
Freundschaft mit dem Westen von Freiheit
und Demokratie und all diesen schönen
Worten erzählt in Wirklichkeit aber
lebten die Menschen in Armut Elend und
Kriminalität
ich hole mein Essen aus der Mülltonne
warum wurde ich geboren aus welchem
Grund
für Ivan und viele andere wird das nicht
besser als Boris Jelzin an die Macht
kommt ein Großteil der Bevölkerung
verliert das Vertrauen in die Regierung
wir hatten diesen Satz
arbeitet am Schreibtisch das hieß das
jetzt hin zu viel getrunken hatte und
nicht öffentlich auftreten konnte
[Musik]
auch Jelzins Verhältnis zum Westen sorgt
für Kopfschütteln
es war offensichtlich das Klinken ihn
auslachte und ihm dabei auf die Schulter
klopfte kein schöner Anblick
eine Schande
die Dinge ändern sich dramatisch im Jahr
2000 putin wird Präsident
von Anfang an Hoffnung geweckt
ich bitte Sie dem russischen Volk den
Eid zu leisten
das Wichtigste war die Ordnung wieder
herzustellen jeder wünschte sich das und
genau das hatte Putin offensichtlich vor
Putins neuer Herrschaftsstil wird
erstmals deutlich als er die
Unabhängigkeitsbestrebungen der
Tschetschenen niederschlagen lässt
putin will auch das Ansehen Russlands in
der Welt wiederherstellen
und die Ausdehnung der NATO in Richtung
Osten stoppen
[Musik]
1999 treten Polen Ungarn und die
Tschechische Republik der NATO bei
2004 stießen sich gleich sieben Ost- und
mitteleuropäische Länder an vier weitere
folgen in den kommenden Jahren
in den Augen vieler Russen bricht der
Westen damit ein Versprechen aus der
gorbatschowzeit
Louis
als der Westen sagte die NATO ist nicht
gegen uns haben wir das geglaubt dann
wurde uns klar dass sie gelogen haben
und dass sie lügen wenn sie nur den Mund
aufmachen
die Natur ist ein Verteidigungsbündnis
und die neuen Mitglieder beantragen alle
selbstständig die Aufnahme in die
Allianz
doch als auch noch die Ukraine in die
Nato will ist für Moskau eine rote Linie
überschritten
zwar ist die Ukraine seit 1991 souverän
und unabhängig doch Teile des
Nachbarlands hatten zuvor mehr als zwei
Jahrhunderte zu Russland gehört
[Musik]
ich habe das Gefühl dass eine Nation
wiedergeboren wurde
Nationalisten wie Ivan condercov glauben
die Ukraine gehören zu Russland
ich bin fast 40 Jahre alt die Ukraine
ist jünger für mich ist es schwierig ein
Land ernst zu nehmen das jünger ist als
ich historisch gesehen ist die Ukraine
so gut wie nichts es ist als wäre sie
gestern entstanden
Russlands Propaganda behauptet seit
Jahren die Unabhängigkeit der Ukraine
sei ein Hirngespinst
Generation die Idee eines russischen
Imperiums und die Verachtung für unsere
Nachbarvölker besonders der Kleinen
werden schon in der Schule gelernt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der aktuelle Konflikt beginnt mit den
maidan-demonstrationen Ende 2013 in Kiew
drei Monate Proteste den Pro russischen
Präsidenten victoriano kovic wird
Korruption vorgeworfen und dass er die
Annäherung an europa-
der Präsident schickt die Polizei auf
den Maidan etwa 100 Menschen sterben
Janukowitsch flieht nach Russland eine
neue pro westliche Regierung übernimmt
die macht doch die Ukraine bleibt
gespalten
[Musik]
eine Woche später lässt Putin die Krim
besetzen
von Moskau gesteuerte Separatisten
bringen die aus ukrainischen Regionen
Johannes und Don jetzt unter ihre
Kontrolle ihr Ziel ist der Anschluss an
Russland
[Musik]
der Armee Veteran Wladimir Orloff ist
seit Jahren aktive Unterstützer der
Russland treuen Separatisten in der
Ukraine
ich weiß technischer Direktor in einer
Reihe von Großunternehmen tätig das
Leben hat es gut mit mir gemeint und ich
dachte es sei an der Zeit etwas
zurückzugeben also habe ich beschlossen
mich zu engagieren
seit 2014 unterstützt er die russische
sprachige Bevölkerung in donbas die
Souveränität der Ukraine will er nicht
akzeptieren
die Ukraine gehört zu Russland ja dort
lebt eine heterogene Bevölkerung
ein Teil dieser Bevölkerung will in die
NATO ein anderer Teil möchte Teil
Russland sein
dieser Teil der Bevölkerung wurde seiner
Stimme beraubt unser Ziel ist es diesen
Menschen das Recht auf eine politische
Wahl und eine politische Stimme
zurückzugeben
Vladimir or love glaubt der Don Bass
soll im Stich gelassen werden während
die übrige Ukraine gen westenstrebe
es sei die Pflicht Russlands
einzugreifen auch mit Gewalt
im Donbass hatte ich das Gefühl einer
Zeitreise als wenn die Sowjetunion noch
existieren würde
in den 30 Jahren ihrer Unabhängigkeit
hat die ukrainische Regierung keinen
einzigen Rubeln investiert die Straßen
waren kaputt die Infrastruktur veraltet
die Fabriken funktioniert nicht die
Menschen hatten nichts
natürlich haben sie gehofft dass ich ihr
Leben ändert wenn Russland wieder die
Macht übernimmt
nimm die Kamera weg
[Musik]
die Pro russischen Separatisten führen
Krieg gegen die Ukraine
Vladimir Orloff will dabei sein
[Musik]
wir haben der Zivilbevölkerung in den
umkämpften Gebieten so gut es ging
geholfen
indem wir Lebensmittel Medikamente und
warme Sachen geliefert haben
[Musik]
das werde für nationale Werte gekämpft
an die er glaube
die Separatisten in luhans und dann
jetzt sollen wissen dass Millionen
Russen hinter ihnen stehen
für mich ist das was in der Ukraine
geschieht eine persönliche Provokation
eine Provokation gegen mein historisches
familiäres Erbe und dagegen werde ich
kämpfen
die Opfer des Konflikts kommen nicht nur
aus dem was
am 17 Juli 2014 wird ein
Verkehrsflugzeug von einer Rakete
getroffen
ich erinnere mich noch genau an den Tag
als Flug mh 17 abgeschossen wurde
eine schreckliche Tragödie
[Musik]
298 Menschen sterben die meisten sind
Niederländer
die Regierung in den hach leitet eine
Untersuchung ein wer hat mh17
abgeschossen
[Musik]
die Ermittler kommen zu dem Schluss eine
Rakete russischer Bauart müsse das
Flugzeug getroffen haben
das russische Staatsfernsehen hält
dagegen ohne neue Beweise zu
präsentieren aber mit dem Ziel die
Schuld vom Russland abzulenken
[Musik]
es gab die Verschwörungstheorie ein
ukrainisches Militärflugzeug vom Typ
su25 habe die Maschine abgeschossen
haben das Kampfflugzeug habe eine Luft
Luft Rakete abgefeuert
dann tauchte die Version auf Ukraine
hätten die Boeing vom Boden aus
abgeschossen
erklärte ein ehemaliger ukrainischer
Offizier eine ukrainische bugrakete habe
das Flugzeug abgeschossen
haben das Flugzeug des russischen
Präsidenten abzuschießen dass ich
gleichzeitig in gleicher Höhe im
polnischen Luftraum
befandliche Ziel könnte in der Tat das
Flugzeug des russischen Präsidenten
gewesen sein eine vertrauliche Quelle
teilte Interfax am Vorabend mit dass die
russische Luftwaffe 1 und die Boeing die
aus Amsterdam kam sich an derselben
Stelle im selben Luftraum kreuzten
zwischendurch
wie Millionen Russen die den staatlichen
Medien glauben hält der Blogger
ivankondercov weitere Diskussionen über
mh17 für sinnlos so oder so die Ukrainer
seien schuld
jedem ist klar dass es für Flugzeuge
gefährlich war in diesem Teil des
Luftraums zu fliegen warum wurde es von
der ukrainischen Flugsicherheit dorthin
geleitet
sie würden ihr Kind ja auch nicht zum
Spielen auf die Autobahn schicken warum
hat die Ukraine den Luftraum nicht
gesperrt
ändert der Kreml mit dem Abschluss von
mh17 seine Propaganda
operieren und Russland müsse alles tun
um sie zu vernichten
Nationalsozialismus präsentiert
die russische Propaganda funktioniert
wie bei Göbbels je unglaublicher die
Lüge desto schneller werden die Menschen
sie glauben sie lassen sich verrücktere
Ideen einfallen um alle zu verwirren am
Ende weiß niemand mehr was Wahrheit und
was Lüge ist
Putins Propagandamaschine hat das Land
in den Krieg getrieben aber Hetze allein
bringt noch nicht den Sieg
das ist Aufgabe der russischen Armee mit
Soldaten wie dem Infanteristen Nikita
Tschechien
Nikita kommt aus Sibirien
[Musik]
das Leben dort ist hart im Winter fällt
die Temperatur auf unter minus 50 Grad
ich wurde in der Stadt ja kurz geboren
ging dort in den Kindergarten und dann
zur Schule zum Studieren bin ich
fortgegangen
aber das hat nicht geklappt
[Musik]
Nikita hat keine Ausbildung kein Geld
keine Zukunft
es gibt für ihn nur eine Chance die
Armee
ich konnte dort eine Ausbildung machen
keine militärische eine zivile und dann
dort arbeiten
[Musik]
wenn ich gewusst hätte dass es am Ende
zu einem Krieg kommt hätte ich mich auf
keinen Fall gemeldet
im Januar 2022 erhalten Nikita und seine
Einheit den Befehl mit dem Zug von
rabadovskamp Pazifik fast 9000 km zu
fahren
ziel ist ein Truppenübungsplatz in
Weißrussland
uns wurde gesagt wir würden dort
ausgebildet gemeinsame Übungen mit den
Belarussen durchführen und dann wieder
nach Hause fahren
während der langen Reise leidet die
Disziplin der Einheit
im Zug haben alle getrunken getrunken
und provoziert das sollte die Armee sein
es war furchtbar und man konnte nicht
sagen oder tun
ich wurde mit einem Messer bedroht
betrunkene Soldaten sagten sie würden
mich töten
als sie in Weißrussland ankommen weiß
niemand wie es weitergeht
aber am Ende gab es gar keine Manöver
wir lebten in Zelten machten uns essen
schliefen Surfen im Internet saßen rum
und hatten nichts
[Musik]
in den frühen Morgenstunden des 24
februar wird klar worum es in Wahrheit
geht
Putin gibt den Befehl zum Überfall auf
die Ukraine
24 Februar 5 Uhr alle Aufstehen vorwärts
gutes geht los und wohin die Ukraine was
ich habe mich geweigert ich habe gesagt
ich will nicht
wenn irgendjemand versucht sich uns in
den Weg zu stellen oder gar unser Volk
zu bedrohen sollte er wissen dass
Russland sofort reagiert das wird zu
Konsequenzen führen wie Ihr sie noch nie
erlebt habt
[Musik]
der Krieg hat begonnen Nikita will nicht
kämpfen aber er hat keine Wahl
so deswegen ich wollte nicht sterben und
stand einfach da und sie haben mich
damit Gewalt in den
Mannschaftstransporter gesteckt ich saß
also in diesem winzigen Raum und es gab
keine Möglichkeit die Tür zu öffnen sie
war kaputt
seine Einheit rückt nach Süden vor in
Richtung Kiew
die russischen Soldaten plündern und
stehlen was ihnen in die Finger kommt
sie fallen in ein fremdes Land ein
zerstören die Häuser und Klauen bringen
Menschen um und sind dann überrascht
warum mögen uns die Ukraine nicht
Ukraine negativ über Russland denken und
über die russische Armee
dazu kommen die Verbrechen an der
Bevölkerung
waren dort vier Söldner auf der Flucht
sie schnappten sie schließlich
Vergewaltiger waren
hätte sie ins Gefängnis stecken müssen
aber stattdessen hat man sie nur aus der
Armee geworfen was für eine Schande
in Moskau ist die Fernsehjournalistin
Marina of sanikova schockiert von den
Berichten sie arbeitete als Redakteurin
bei Premium Russlands beliebtester
Nachrichtensendung
als der Krieg begann konnte ich nicht
essen nicht trinken nicht schlafen ich
war so aufgewühlt ich wollte gleich am
ersten Tag protestieren aber ich habe
schnell erkannt dass das zu nichts
geführt hätte denn die Polizei steckte
alle in die Gefängniswagen ich stand
schon mit den Autoschlüssel vor der Tür
wollte protestieren fahren aber mein
Sohn hat mir die Schlüssel weggenommen
und mich im Haus eingeschlossen
am 14 März macht sich Marina auf den Weg
zur Arbeit bei Kanal 1
es war ein völlig verrückter Tag ich
wusste ich muss was tun
Widerstand gegen putinskrieg in Russland
führt häufig direkt ins Gefängnis
zuerst wollte ich mit dem Plakat weiter
hinten im Newsroom stehen sich in den
Nachrichten live gegen Putins Krieg zu
stellen ist entweder ungeheuer mutig
oder unglaublich verrückt
im letzten Moment nahm ich das Plakat
und rannte an dem Polizisten vorbei
hinter den Rücken der
Nachrichtensprecherin und hielt das
Plakat direkt in die Kamera
françoğan
ich konnte nicht schweigen und deshalb
schrieb ich kein Krieg Russen gegen den
Krieg
das war eine Botschaft vor allem für den
Westen und für das von der Propaganda
zombiefizierte russische Publikum ich
schrieb sie lügen euch an glaubt der
Propaganda nicht
gestern Moskau ein sehr erfreuliches
Ereignis
im US-Senator und auf der ganzen Welt
sorgt Marinas Protest für Aufsehen wie
werden Putins Behörden reagieren zumal
jemand in Kiel die Aktion öffentlich
bejubelt und das ganz absichtlich auf
russisch
ich bin den Russen dankbar die nicht
aufhören die Wahrheit zu sagen die gegen
Desinformation kämpfen und die wahren
Fakten verbreiten und besonders der
jungen Frau die das Studio von Kanal 1
mit einem Plakat gegen den Krieg
gestürmt hat
Martina
ich bin nicht einverstanden mit der
Informationspolitik von Kanal 1
angeklagt
dann wird sie zu einer Polizeistation
gebracht
war zuständig für politisch
extremistische Straftaten er sagte dies
ist kein Verhör es ist ein freundliches
Gespräch sagen Sie mir einfach für wen
sie arbeiten
[Musik]
auch putin-anhänger von der Kopf hat
Marinas Plakataktion gesehen
in jedem Dorf gibt es den Dorf Trottel
der Dinge Tod von denen er glaubt dass
sie notwendig sind aber die Person kommt
einfach wie ein nah rüber diese Frau hat
bewiesen dass sie ein Idiot ist
wie Ivan gibt es Millionen Russen die
noch immer an Putin und seiner
militärische spezialoperation Glauben
am 21 September 2022 wird ihr Glaube
erschüttert
Putin ordnet eine teilmobilisierung an
300.000 Männer werden einberufen
man hat keine Wahl sie zwingen dich wenn
du nicht gehst kommst du in den Knast
und ich gehe nicht in den Knast
[Musik]
die Menschen die sich nicht an dem
verbrecherischen Krieg beteiligen
wollten haben vor Beginn der
Mobilisierung den Kopf in den Sand
gesteckt aber jetzt zerrt die Hand des
Kremls an ihren Familien und an Ihnen
persönlich
auch der Soldaten Nikita Schweden wird
aufgefordert wieder in den Kampf zu
ziehen seine Motivation ist gleich null
wirklich höre immer noch diese Geräusche
Granaten diese Geräusche von denen ich
niemandem Wünsche die jemals hören zu
müssen niemandem
leidet unter chronischen Schmerzen und
lässt sich in einem Armeekrankenhaus
untersuchen
ich ging zuerst ins Krankenhaus um mich
krankschreiben und meinen Rücken
irgendwie behandeln zu lassen um mich
von dem Schock zu erholen und so weiter
ich hatte den Plan zu fliehen
also ließ sich jede Woche meiner Test
verlängern irgendwann war damit aber
Schluss
um nicht zurück an die Front zu müssen
will Nikita schnell handeln irgendwie
schneiden und dann kam die Nachricht
dass sie die Grenzen schließen also
musste ich mich beeilen
einem schon unterwegs
ich konnte noch ein Ticket für den
nächsten Zug nach Weißrussland ergattern
also renne ich um zum Bahnhof zu kommen
ich habe den Zug noch bekommen in
letzter Sekunde
[Musik]
Zug aber die Grenze kommt erst noch ich
hatte etwas getrunken und war von dem
ganzen Stress völlig weggetreten ich
schlief und schnarchte der Grenzbeamte
kommt rein
will die Dokumente kontrollieren in
diesem Moment musste ich furzen ein
Gasangriff der Gestank traf den
Kontrolleur und der rannte einfach weg
[Musik]
Nikita schafft es nach Weißrussland von
dort aus gelingt ihm die Flucht in den
Westen wo er politisches Asyl beantragt
[Musik]
während des gesamten Krieges beobachtet
der Pro putin-blogger ivankow in Moskau
die Ereignisse von seiner sicheren
Wohnung aus
nur einmal im dezember 2022 besucht er
den Donbass um Material für seine Blogs
zu sammeln
frohes neues Jahr
konterkopf verteilt als Weihnachtsmann
Geschenke seine Reise führte ihn auch
nach mariopold
die Stadt in der einige der schwersten
Schlachten stattgefunden hat ist in
russischer Hand
90% der Gebäude sind zerstört
350.000 Einwohner sind geflohen
es wurde dort heftig gekämpft es gab
viele zivile Opfer Familien Kinder
Frauen nicht nur vom asafregiment und
der ukrainischen Armee es gab auch Opfer
durch russische Bombenangriffe war das
nicht der Fall
wenn man Zivilisten daran hindert
umkämpfte Gebiete zu verlassen kann man
ihre Sicherheit natürlich nicht
gewährleisten
Ivan bestreitet das russische Soldaten
für die vielen Toten verantwortlich sind
aus seiner Sicht wurde die Stadt befreit
ich habe mit den Einheimischen in Mario
Paul gesprochen das erste was mir
auffiel war dass die Menschen jetzt
glücklich sind
ich meine sie sind froh dass die
ukrainische Herrschaft beendet ist
was aus Ivans Perspektive eine Befreiung
ist geht einher mit Zerstörung und Leid
in seinem Block zeichnet er dennoch das
Bild einer Stadt voller Hoffnung im
Aufbruch
[Musik]
hier gibt es ziemlich stark beschädigte
Gebäude im Zentrum der Stadt aber hier
stehen auch schon Stapel von
Pflastersteinen die verlegt werden
können und hier wurden sie bereits
perfekt
hier ist der Park
die Laternen Leuchten also ist der Strom
wieder da
was danach
die Wiederherstellung erfolgt recht
zügig und viele Gebäude insbesondere
beschädigte historische Gebäude sind nun
in Folien gehüllt auf denen zu sehen ist
wie die Häuser nach der Restaurierung
aussehen werden
für Anastasia oder Cover steht der Name
Mario Polen nicht für Hoffnung sondern
für Verbrechen
im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes fehlt die
russische Armee auf Befehl Putins Städte
vom Antlitz der Erde und sagt dass er
ihre Art Gutes zu bringen
ich verstehe nicht wie Menschen so blind
sein können Fotos einer völlig
zerstörten Stadt zu sehen und an eine
Befreiung zu glauben dass das ganze eine
friedenserhaltende Mission der
russischen Armee sein
für Ivan liegt die Wahrheit im Auge des
Betrachters
Mitgefühl für die Opfer hat da keinen
Platz
objektivität ist in der Physik möglich
wenn es ein Phänomen gibt das gemessen
werden kann
aber in den Medien gibt es keine
Objektivität
jeder sieht die Dinge aus seinem eigenen
Blickwinkel
und jeder denkt dass seine Sichtweise
die Sichtweise seines Staates richtig
ist
und dass die Sichtweise der anderen
nicht richtig ist
[Musik]
in Moskau wird der
Nachrichtenredakteurin von Kanal 1
Marina aus janikova wegen ihres
plakatprotests der Prozess gemacht sie
wird zu einer Geldstrafe verurteilt und
entlassen schweigen aber will sie nicht
ich wusste dass viele Kinder in der
Ukraine getötet werden und wollte etwas
tun also habe ich wieder ein Plakat
gemalt und bin direkt zum Kreml gegangen
zwei meiner Freunde haben ein Video
aufgenommen wir haben es noch am selben
Tag gepostet und sind dann direkt zu
meinem Anwalt
der war schockiert und sagte ihr Mädels
seid echt krass
eine Provokation mit folgen
um 6 Uhr morgens hämmerten sie gegen
meine Tür meine Tochter schlief bei mir
und sie riefen wenn sie nicht sofort
öffnen werden wir die Tür aufbrechen
ich wurde verhaftet sie verhirten mich
auf der Polizeistation
es waren wirklich einige der härtesten
Stunden meines Lebens ich war zwei volle
Tage am Stück wach
Marina muss erneut vor Gericht dieses
Mal soll sie falsche Informationen über
die spezialoperation verbreitet haben
darauf stehen in Putins Russland bis zu
zehn Jahre Gefängnis
kommst du ins Gefängnis
niemand wollte eine Frau mit Kind aus
dem Land schleusen
praxisgemäß aber schließlich hat man
Anwalt doch einen Weg gefunden
das bedeutet eine lange Reise auf der
Straße und dann einen heimlichen
Grenzübertritt zu Fuß
[Musik]
das Auto gewechselt natürlich lief nicht
alles nach Plan
hat mein Anwalt sagte vertrauen Sie mir
Sie müssen nur etwa 700 m bis 1 km zur
Grenze gehen
aber dieser eine Kilometer entpuppte
sich am Ende als mehrere Kilometer über
ein Feld dann einen Wald dann einen
kleinen Sumpf
ich habe geschrieben bringt mich zurück
nach Moskau lieber gehe ich ins
Gefängnis als noch einen Schritt weiter
zu gehen
[Musik]
sofort auf der Stelle
zuerst wurde er mit einer Geldstrafe
belegt seine Konten wurden gesperrt er
stand unter Hausarrest
[Musik]
später kam es zu Strafanzeigen er wurde
vergiftet
dann kam er ins Gefängnis
[Musik]
alexa ist einer der bekanntesten
russischen Gegner Putins
nach einem Giftanschlag gegen ihn kehrt
er nach Russland zurück obwohl er weiß
dass ihnen das ins Gefängnis bringt
jetzt lebt der meist in Einzelhaft und
sein Leben ist nach wie vor in Gefahr
[Musik]
navanis Schicksal ist eine ständige
Mahnung an alle Russen die Putins macht
in Frage stellen
Marinas Flucht ist erfolgreich sie
beantragt Asyl in Paris
niemand weiß wie lange der Krieg noch
dauern wird
die Ukraine ist das Schlachtfeld aber
auch durch Russland läuft ein Riss
[Musik]
die eine Seite steht zu Putin die andere
will das Russland den Krieg verliert
die Zukunft Russlands hängt in erster
Linie von der Ukraine ab je schneller
Sie diesen Krieg gewinnt desto schneller
Gerät Putin auf die Verlierer Straße
desto schneller wird dieses Regime
zusammenbrechen
für Putin und seine Anhänger ist nur ein
Sieg akzeptabel
für die Verteidigung Russlands und
unseres Volkes werden wir alle uns zur
Verfügung stehenden Mittel einsetzen das
ist kein Glück
[Musik]
Putin und seine Armee von Bloggern und
Kriegstreibern haben keine Skrupel den
Einsatz von Atomwaffen anzudrehen
ich denke das wahrscheinlichste Szenario
für einen Atomkrieg ist Russland wird
gezwungen sein einen Präventivschlag
gegen eine europäische Hauptstadt zu
führen wahrscheinlich London oder Berlin
und genau damit wird es auch enden
[Musik]
wir Russen werden uns den Folgen dieses
Krieges stellen und den Preis dafür
zahlen müssen wie lange der Krieg dauern
und was der endgültige Preis sein wird
werden wir erst am Ende sehen was wir
anscheinend
[Musik]